Zuckerberg has finally given up on the
metaverse to most of you this probably
isn't that surprising within just the
past two years the metaverse has lost
meta 24 billion dollars but despite the
Hefty losses the memes and the
lackluster adoption rates it seemed like
Zuckerberg was willing to push forward
it no matter what he was ready to bet a
hundred billion dollars on the metaverse
over the next couple of years so there
was plenty of Headroom left but it seems
like there was one factor that was big
enough to scare him away from the
metaverse shareholders Zuckerberg
technically has over 50 voting control
at The Meta so he's allowed to do
whatever he wants and no one can fire
him but that doesn't mean that he can do
whatever he wants and this stock will
perform well if investors don't believe
in the future of the company they're
gonna dump this dock in masses and
that's exactly what's been happening at
meta between late 2021 and the late 2022
Mata stock plummeted an eye-watering 77
this translates to a market cap loss of
wait for it 808 billion dollars it looks
like this is exactly the reality check
that Zuckerberg needed as he completely
shifted his tone on the metaverse of
course he hasn't publicly denounced the
metaverse or admitted that it's a
failure but actions speak louder than
words within the past six months meta
has laid off a total of 21
000 employees this equates to about 25
of their total Workforce and I think you
can guess which department was affected
the most also the layoffs may not even
be done yet there's rumors that meta may
have one last round of layoffs in May so
by the time you're watching this meta
may have laid off another five to ten
thousand employees this would
effectively bring meta's employee
account down to pre pandemic of
pre-mediverse levels Zuckerberg has also
completely stopped talking about the
metaverse I wonder why unsurprisingly
though this has a lot of meta to destroy
their recent earnings report and that's
despite still paying mountains and
Severance within the next six months or
so as the severance phases out Madoff
will not only be larger than ever but it
will also be more efficient than ever
investors couldn't ask for her anything
more and they've already started the
price in this scenario within just the
past six months meta stock has bounced
back nearly 200 percent
this has a lot of meta to reclaim their
spawn as a fortune 10 company and for
Zuckerberg to add a cool 42 billion onto
his fortune just this year alone so
here's the story of Zuckerberg's insane
gamble with the metaphors and how he
managed to walk away stronger than ever
[Music]
taking a look back the story of the
metaverse dates back nearly 10 years at
this point to 2014. at the time Facebook
would acquire Oculus for 2 billion
dollars which allowed them to take their
first steps into the world of virtual
reality Facebook wasn't alone in this
Venture as a bunch of big tech companies
were also interested in this future
Samsung and Sony were working hard at
creating their own VR products and who
could forget about Google cardboard but
over the years most of these companies
have scaled back their VR efforts or
straight up discontinued their projects
altogether they could all see what we
saw the tech just wasn't ready for Mass
adoption but despite the early red flags
Facebook would not only lean into VR but
Mark would go on to bet the entire
future of the company on it so what
happened well a lot of Mark's choices
make a lot more sense when it's
contextualized with the state of
Facebook as a whole by the second half
of the 2010s Zuckerberg had come to the
realization that social media is
extremely fickle there is always a new
kid on the Block that soaking up all the
attention first there was a Friendster
then Myspace then Facebook then
Instagram then Snapchat then Tick Tock
and now potentially be real so the
reality was that it was just a matter of
time until Facebook was replaced at
first Facebook tried to address this by
just buying out the new kid for stupid
sums of money he bought Instagram for 1
billion dollars and WhatsApp for 19
billion dollars but flexing his world
only got him so far pretty soon the
people that he was trying to buy out
started to reject his deals Snapchat was
likely the first notable example
rejecting a three billion buyout from
Facebook
realizing that he couldn't just buy out
everyone Mark naturally shifted his
strategy to copying everyone at the end
of 2012 for example Facebook launched
poke which was a Shameless ripoff of
Snapchat you probably don't even
remember this though as it was such a
massive flop learning from this Facebook
would stop trying to launch new apps
instead they would just Implement
popular features into their existing
apps for example the implemented stories
and Rios into Instagram but while these
features were decently successful for
Instagram they by no means stopped
Snapchat or Tick Tock from succeeding in
their own right
so by the late 2010s Mark understood
that he couldn't just buy or copy his
way into stability the only way to
achieve stability was to shift to a more
stable industry his dream with Facebook
was always to build a social Highway and
use advertisers as tollbooths the hole
in this plan is that when it comes to
social highways people are always moving
cities what Mark really wanted was to
control something like the internet but
it was obviously impossible for Facebook
to take over the Internet itself in the
late 2010s if they wanted to control
something so large the only option was
to get in early and do the next internet
and this brings us into Mark's obsession
with virtual reality or the metaverse
things didn't start off hopeless for the
metaverse in fact they started off
pretty bright actually Oculus was by far
the most respected player within the VR
scene and hardcore Gamers loved their
products but there was one major
limiting factor cost Oculus headsets
were simply unaffordable for the masses
the Oculus Rift came and had 600 which
in itself isn't cheap but that was by no
means the only expense the rift was a
tethered headset meaning that it had to
be connected to a PC to function of
course you could connect the headset to
your beaten up laptop but if you wanted
any sort of meaningful VR experience you
had to buy a multi-thousand dollar PC
which just wasn't practical for the
average Joe so Zuckerberg decided to
address this concern head-on with the
meta Quest 2 which came in at a mere 300
to 400 no PC required suddenly the price
of VR was comparable to that of a gaming
console in fact it was cheaper than most
gaming consoles the main reason for this
was that meta was taking up massive
losses on these units but that was okay
they just wanted everyone to buy and use
the darn thing and they could figure out
how to monetize later initially it
seemed like their plan was playing out
perfectly given the hype around VR and
the relatively affordable price of the
meta Quest 2 people were buying it in
the masses in fact meta has sold it
nearly 20 million of these headsets but
there was just one Teensy tiny problem
no one was using the headsets people
were to buy it tried out for a few days
and then use it as a dust collector
indefinitely
why you ask well the biggest reason is
simply that the experience just sucks
the entire point of ER is to have an
immersive almost real life experience
and the only way to do that is to use
powerful Nvidia gpus paired with
airplane jet engines as coolers when you
try to do the same thing with an iPhone
chip for 400 well a 360 degree me world
is what you get the hardware was so
limited that Mata couldn't even produce
legs for your avatars much less make
them look realistic in fact they
couldn't even produce legs for
demonstration purposes they would end up
cheating using pre-rendered animations
and don't even get me started on the
Enterprise side of things Mark was
selling the metaverse as a way for
business professionals to conduct more
authentic virtual meetings that felt
like real life not a bad idea in theory
but with the graphics like this these
meetings by no means felt professional
and genuine
if anything they felt childish and out
of place in a corporate setting not to
mention expensive unsurprisingly
virtually every company has decided to
stick with the teams in Zoom we should
mention that after receiving all this
negative feedback about lackluster
immersion meta would come out with a
higher end headset called the metaquest
pro for fifteen hundred dollars but by
the time this headset came out the pros
were already out and the reputation of
the metaverse had already been tarnished
not to mention the pro wasn't all that
much better to begin with so let's just
say the metaquest pro wasn't received
very well and the meta would end up
slashing the price by 500 just 5 months
after release marking the beginning of
the end
there's really no way to sugarcoat it
meta is pulling back on the metaverse
hard and it's no wonder why they're far
from producing the tech and experience
they want to developing the metaverse is
taking a massive toll on the company's
bottom line and stock price and the
reputation of the metaverse is beyond
repair now of course if you ask
Zuckerberg he'll tell you that they're
by no means ditching the metaverse but
all of the evidence is against this for
starters meta has laid off a quarter of
their Workforce with the median salary
of three hundred thousand dollars this
is saving Facebook roughly 6.3 billion
dollars every year seems
counterintuitive for someone who's
planning on investing 100 billion into
the metaverse but likely the best
evidence that meta is indeed moving away
from the metaverse is the fact that
Zuckerberg has become obsessed with
something else AI according to meta CTO
Andrew Bosworth Mark metis Chief Park
office officer Chris Cox and him are all
spending most of their time working on
AI and more specifically generative AI
it seems that the Mark has very much
gotten caught up with the chat GPT hype
and he wants to get a piece of the
action meta has even announced their own
large language model called Lama and
they're currently working on releasing
this to researchers Bosworth has also
confirmed that they're working on
releasing a commercial AI product by the
end of this year all of this may seem a
bit confusing and seems like Zuckerberg
was super gung-ho about the metaverse so
how did he pivot so quickly well the
reality is simply that meta's commitment
to the metaverse was simply overhyped by
the media in fact the metaverse wasn't
even Zuckerberg's first attempt to Pivot
Facebook away from social media before
he got obsessed with VR Zuckerberg was
actually trying to build a space
business he was launching a bunch of
solar powered drones and Atmospheric
satellites with the goal of trying to
create satellite-based internet similar
to starlink today but as he saw that
this wasn't picking up any Steam and
that SpaceX was gonna do it themselves
Zuckerberg didn't hesitate to kill off
the program completely and switched the
metaverse so who's to say that
Zuckerberg isn't willing to do the same
thing with the metaverse
foreign
[Music]
that the metaverse was much more
consumer oriented and futuristic than
their space plan it garnered a lot more
media attention but for Facebook it was
just another attempt to break free from
social media by now though it's become
clear that this path is not so viable
and they're accordingly playing back
substantially this isn't to say that
meta is completely ditching the
metaverse quite yet there are still
pouring resources into the idea but
they're by no means adamant is sticking
to just that if they can get something
else to work instead like AI even better
the bottom line is that meta has become
a mature social media company meaning
that they only have two paths moving
forward they can either go all in on
social media optimize their operations
and become a dividend Giant or they can
try to hit the next big thing
with this performance over the past six
months Zuckerberg has made it clear that
he can achieve the former at any time
within a matter of 12 months if he wants
to but what he really wants is the
latter he wants to grow meta to the next
magnitude and the only way to do that is
to hit a grand slam he took a few swings
at the metaverse and it looks like he
struck out but being only 38 years old
with the majority control over the
eighth largest company in the world I
assure you he has a lot of swings left
so while people love mocking the
metaverse it's Zuckerberg that's getting
the last laugh are you a fan of the
metaverse comment that down below also
drop a like if you think that people
would be better off focusing on their
own lives instead of critiquing others
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community Successful video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]